[Music]
Aladin in Little Mermaid poor Ariel I
see where you're going with this and
it's not nice I'm gonna do lion can't
princess and frog I don't know I'm gonna
do tangled
yeah I'm gonna do Moana just Aladdin for
sure
mermaid I'll do before this side up so
good
Toy Story Coco hmm
Thanks okay bug's life Finding Nemo
Monsters Inc and I'll definitely do the
Incredibles okay now it's getting
getting tough
Lion King here
[Music]
Milana oh it's our this one's no this
one's not nice
those are two of my favorites that's sad
I gotta come back to that one and this
one I'll do nightmare incredible Nemo
Wow mmm Toy Story 3 here Aladdin and
little mummy
I'm gonna go Aladdin poor Ariel for me
personally I'm gonna go up here
I'm gonna go The Incredibles Wow
I see where you're going with this and
it's not nice it's not right to make
people do this okay so this I would also
little adenine and of the two I would
still go Lion King Wow Wow up
so now I'm at Lion King and up
[Music]
it was so moving everybody knows that
those first ten minutes of that movie
are like shock it you're like you don't
know me I mean the fact that they get
you so invested in those in those
characters so quickly that you
completely are you know devastated when
one of them is dead it's very emotional
I think I had seen it too and I I just
got married
having been managed for very long so it
was a very difficult decision for me I'm
broken up about it I'm hurt that I had
to that I had to choose I blame these
people they made me make the choice I
would I would never have made it we
don't live in a world where you have to
choose between these two things these
people have designed this awful thing
for us to do blame business insider you
send your hate tweets to them
[Music]
you